hello everybody
super excited to be here with you at
cloud native rust days
for those of you who haven't had the
pleasure to meet yet my name is luca
palmieri and i work as a lead engineer
for toulair a financial technology
company based in london
i've been contributing to the russ
community for the past three and a half
years you might have seen some of the
work i did to get people interested into
the language workshops code dodgers with
the last london user group
or you might have used some of the
packages i maintain cargo chef for
faster docker builds or wiremock to test
some of your rest api clients
for the past 12 months or so i've mostly
been focused on driving zero to
production in rust
zero the production rust is a book that
guides a developer which is new to the
ecosystem or new to the domain
in understanding what is available and
how to make use of it efficiently to
actually build cloud native applications
and some of the topics that are touched
in the book will also form some of the
material for this talk
coming to the matter at end
what drives most of the conversation
we're going to be having today is the
work we've been doing at true layer for
the past year
to layer build a new product line called
pay direct the details of it don't
matter necessarily too much you can
think of pay direct as an api which
allows a merchant
to manage what looks like a bank account
so they're funds held by two layer they
can receive payments from the rest in
the ecosystem and they can initiate
payments uh towards other accounts on
the network all of it done by apis
there's one question that keeps being
asked over and over again
why
why have you chosen bust
and one side of the question we might
frame as a question of novelty
rust
no matter how ozone we believe it is
it's still a young programming language
uh 1.0 came out shortly
five years ago more or less
compared to the age of maturity of
ecosystems like the jvm like
the clr
like python and typescript is still
fairly young
so that there's an inner and element of
risk and we're going to touch on some of
those later on
but the other part
the other like intent behind the
question
is actually confusion between what
people think trust is and what we're
using russ for and that's because rust
has
made a lot of his early victories and a
lot of his most striking successes in a
different domain
not in cloud native applications but in
system programming
and this is a little scrapbook that i
put together in like five to ten minutes
of just high profile projects that not
so long ago have been on the headlines
for using rust
all of these things are massive
accomplishment especially if we go back
to what we were discussing a few moments
ago considering our young two languages
but all of these massive accomplishments
fall within the domain of system
programming
and as people like to remember me you
are not doing system programming
so a lot of the things that matter
in system programming uh memory safety
um
squeezing out milliseconds by being very
careful by your locating memory adding
binaries which are very small because
you're deploying them on constrained
devices
don't necessarily matter in the
cloud-native ecosystem
we often are constrained not by how fast
our programs are but on how fast we can
develop them how many mistakes we make
along the way
how fast can we fix those and how fast
most importantly can we evolve that
software over time
speed of iteration is almost always the
biggest constraint in big cloud native
deployments especially microservice
architectures
so
why are we using a language which was
engineered to solve problems which are
not the problems of the cloud native
ecosystem
you don't have to draw a wall between
different domains
things which are good for system
programmer can be equally interesting
and equally beneficial to people working
in back-end development the same applies
to front-end and other domains like game
development which are usually seen as
very silent and not communicating with
one another
actually by fraying outside of what is
familiar we can find out that some of
the problems they have are some of the
problems we have if you look a little
bit under the surface
and the solutions can be reused and can
be the foundation to build something
much more interesting for what we want
to solve
and that's pretty much going to be the
theme of this whole talk
like you have seen the title
we're going to talk about the good the
bad and the ugly of using grass for the
club native development and this is of
course based on our own very specific
experience and i'm sure that different
people coming from different backgrounds
trying to solve different problems might
have a different take but i think it's
important to start to break to an extent
the strong association that rust has
with system programming
so let's start from what is good once
again people remember beginning at the
end so put the bed in the middle
are the best aspects of rust when it
comes to cloud native development
well the number one for me and like a
cute 80 percent or why i love to use the
language today
is that i'm able to compose
smaller bits of functionality into
larger program
without having surprises found at
runtime so let's look at an example
let's look at this function verify
signature
text.json web token as argument and it
returns us the claims
uh inside the json web token
now if this was within a different
programming language depending on what
the language was uh this might look
slightly different
in a dynamic language uh you wouldn't
have the types
so you would infer that anything that
behaves like a token in some not very
well defined way
is going to be a valid input
and then you would have to write a bunch
of tests to make sure that anything
which is not a valid input
fails in a predictable manner for
example raising an exception
and that is his own problems right is
somebody's coming back to the code base
tomorrow they don't know about all those
assumptions because they're not in the
run they have not loaded all the
implicit knowledge required by the code
base and they might make mistakes
and if those are not tested for then
those mistakes might arrive in
production we don't like that
if you move to something which is
statically typed
like c sharp or java
then what you might have is something
similar so a function which is marked as
a synchronous so it does some input
output it might be over the network it
might be over disk
it takes as input a token and you would
definitely have a gwt type which has
some constraints encoded inside the type
and it would return some claims
but that function
might mutate the gwt token and passing
to it as an input
and also it might fail but the signature
doesn't tell me that it might fail
that's because they're using exceptions
to signal that some things might not
complete successfully but i don't see in
the signature what exception that
function can raise which means that i
either need to go and look at the source
code and inspect
every line to understand if it might
throw an exception or i need to be very
defensive so need to add
try catch statements which are very
broad to make sure that they actually
fulfill all the different corner cases
now let's go back to rust
once again i have a scene keyword on the
left that tells me this function might
do io that's great
the token not only is the gwt which
tells me something about the structure
of the input i also know that i'm
passing in a reference to touchywt and
that's an immutable reference that means
that i know that my verify signature
function relaxes the gwt but it won't
mutate it
and that already simplifies massively
debugging for example if you're trying
to understand where things go wrong
knowing that
your data is not changing unless it's
very explicitly demarked as being
mutable makes it much much faster you
can rule out massive
parts of the call tree without even
looking at those
and equally important
at the end i know immediately that this
function can fail because this function
returns a result now result is a way to
encode inside the type system
that if things go well i'll get a claims
but if things go wrong i'll get an error
that error the verification error i can
go and look at the definition and i can
see all the different cases most likely
is going to be an enum
and i can decide what to do in each of
those cases
this allows me to reason
about what matters to my software when
calling your software without actually
having to go inside and do technical due
diligence of your implementation
and that's the basis for powerful reuse
being able to actually isolate and
encapsulate complexity
by exposing just what matters to the
person using the abstraction
empowers us to build towers which are
much higher and much more robust than
what we can do if we stack things on top
of each other without controlling all
these effects
let's get to this second pattern which
is actually very important when writing
cloud native dress code
being able to write state machines sid
machines are everywhere in your programs
you have resources that most likely have
a life cycle of sort
a user a user might sign up they might
confirm their email and then they might
suspend their account or close their
account
a payment gets authorized then it gets
booked then it gets submitted then it
gets settled or it fails
they have a finite number of states
which are valid and they are very clear
business rules on how to go from state a
to state b
and it's also clear that you can go from
state a to state c
this is extremely difficult to encode if
you're using class hierarchies like you
can have an infinite number of
subclasses
instead if you're using rust you can
encode these finite state machines using
algebraic types so using genomes in and
switch are able to have values so each
of the variants can contain a payload is
not just
a fancy way of having an integer zero
one two zero bending one active to
suspended each of those is actually
struct which has fields can be
constructed and used
and they're finite so you know if you
actually used and verified all the
possible parts every time you're using a
user
let's make an example
and this is classic when you start
modeling a domain you don't know exactly
all the different corner cases
so if you're starting to write your
platform you might say well a user is
either pending or active
and that's because the world is simple
right you don't have users yet like your
biggest focus at that point in time is
getting more users
so you focus on the user creation part
of the user life cycle
so you go to production with pending
inactive and all the different parts of
your code basis know what to do if a
user is spending and if a user is active
at a certain point in time you realize
the user might want to freeze their
accounts you have become successful now
i have a sizable user base now this new
part of the lifecycle enters your domain
model
and you need to make sure that
everywhere in your code base when you're
handling a user you also are taking the
appropriate action if the user is
suspended for example they shouldn't be
able to look in and rust
helps you massively here because enums
being finite so they're not open-ended
class hierarchy that a finite number of
states
allows the compiler to actually do
exhaustive matching so every time you
want to use a user you need to match on
that user and you need to have a match
arm for every possible variant the
moment you introduce a new variant
the compiler will scream at you with all
the different places in the code base
which require you to handle the new
variant and then you know that until it
compiles you actually can move forward
and that is just amazing because
you're using technology to scale up your
mental model in a complex code base
written by somebody else involved by
somebody else afterwards which you
landed on 15 days ago you don't know all
the cool parts you don't know all the
places where the user is used but
technology is there to help you scale
your understanding is there to help you
fall into the beat of success
third good part of grass for cloud
native development
predictable performance
and i want to stress the word
predictable so i'm not here to talk
about the fact that rust is fast for
most of the application doesn't matter
as we said before the biggest constraint
when doing enterprise software
is how fast can you iterate
and in most cases if your application
takes 70 milliseconds instead of 100
instead of 150
doesn't actually make a massive
difference to the user
in certain places it does like there are
bottlenecks in the system where you want
to be as fast as possible but there are
also plenty of parts where speed doesn't
matter
what matters though is being able to
reason about the system as a whole and
being able to reason about the way it's
going to behave in a consistent fashion
so what matters is when looking at your
latency lines is seeing something flat
so i want to know that
fetching the settings for the client is
going to take on average 50 milliseconds
and it's much easier to reason about the
behavior of the system if it always
takes 50 milliseconds
if from time to time it takes 50 but
sometimes it takes 300
then the situation is much more
complicated and that happens a lot if
you're using garbage collective
languages but it's much easier to reason
about your system if everything you need
to look at is the code you have written
and brass being able to free memory in a
deterministic fashion thanks to the
border checker and lifetime tracking
actually give you that super flat line
now not everything is roses and rainbows
certain things are not working at the
moment when it comes to using rust for
cloud native ecosystem
and actually my list is not particularly
long there's one items but i think it's
massive
compilation times
fast
compile times are long
we have applications a true layer which
are
reasonably complex uh and take up to 15
16 minutes to compile
in release mode
so when we're building docker images to
release in production on on our local
machines
incremental compilation caching
the experience is fairly smooth
but we are experiencing a lengthening of
the feedback loop which is actually very
very important in a company which is
write code commit merge to master deploy
observe
the merge buster
deploy
step is too long
i can't wait 15 minutes to go from
code is in my trunk to code is running
in production
continuous deployment is the temp of
your organization if you have an
organization that can only deploy once
every 15 minutes that means that you can
make four experiments per hour and you
can make with like awesome usage of your
time which doesn't happen
uh 32 experiments per day in reality
probably that's something like 20
because i put something in ci then i do
something else i forget waste a bunch of
minutes then i go back and so on and so
forth
if i can deploy every two minutes
i can make the same number of
experiments within a single hour and
within a day i can iterate on so many
different configurations that actually i
can convert to what i need much faster
this is probably
the most threatening aspect of the last
programming language today when it comes
to adoption within the cloud native
ecosystem
now that's not to say that all the rest
is amazing but the rest they classify as
ugly ugly means that the situation as of
today is not optimal
but there is a clear part to get those
things unblocked and to make them better
first one is ecosystem maturity and we
touched on this point at the very
beginning rust is a young language and
rust in the cloud-native ecosystem
specifically is even younger because
rust really became viable to do backhand
development from the moment we got a
sync await and it got a sync await in
november 2019.
and let's factor in four or five months
for the ecosystem kind of to shift to
use the sync weight we're talking like
mid-2020
and there's a lot of exploration that
still needs to happen in the ecosystem
to understand what ergonomic means what
are the best practices of using that
feature of the language
therefore the ecosystem is moving like
there's a bit of churn uh libraries are
still evolving
and that might create a little bit of
additional work
the other side of it
is that a lot of libraries do not exist
as of today
i'm talking about
libraries to interact with big vendors
you want to use aws that is risotto
great you want to use gcp
uh well you might have to write a bunch
of stuff on your own you want to use
volt
same story so you cannot consider as you
might do for example in python or in
note
the open source ecosystem as a vendor
you are shopping from
once you use a package in rust which is
open source you need to take into
account that you might have to devote a
percentage of your development time to
actually go and contribute to that
library it might be that the
documentation is missing a bit it might
be that there is uh an unusual code path
that you are exercising which is not as
well tested
factor that in like go inside in the
ecosystem with your eyes wide open it
happened to us as well like over a year
we contributed i think almost 10
different patches to fairly well known
projects so we're not talking projects
with one or two stars
so be ready for doing your part in
pushing the ecosystem forward
the second one and i know this is like
once again top of the agenda for many
different people
rus does not ship an async executor
inside the standard library rust shapes
the future trait so shapes the interface
on what doing an asynchronous task looks
like
but it pushes the actual logic to
orchestrate those asynchronous tasks
into libraries
at the moment we have tokyo on one side
the oldest executor then we have a sing
stood now we're bastian and a bunch of
others with specialized use cases and
it's not easy to interoperate we don't
want libraries to have to choose in
which
which side they're playing i want to be
able to buy the library that works with
most executors and that requires us
standardizing on certain traits and
requires us making sure that that
experience works
and i know this is one of the focus of
the async fusion effort that is getting
started in the past couple of months and
i'm sure we're going to see improvements
but as of today
i think that i recommend to beginners
which i don't like is pick an executor
to stick to it because that's going to
make your experience simpler i would
like to see a future where these advance
is not necessary
third intermediate learning resources
rust is amazing when it comes to getting
beginners into the language you have the
rust book you have programming with
trust you have rust in action you have
awesome video series on youtube of
different kinds and levels
but when you want to do cloud native
development there's a lot more that is
not in those resources
a seeing kawaii for example is often not
contemplated what libraries to use now
discussed how to stitch them together
not really discussed
part of this is why i brought zero to
production bust is like
i don't plan to have this as an official
resource this is as the title says an
opinionated way of getting something
that works or putting a bunch of tools
inside the box and getting you something
that you can use we trust to make these
kind of programs
but i'd like to see more like i like to
see more resources with different angles
uh videos books that take a different
approach people need to have the
possibility to choose how to approach
the ecosystem because everybody learns
differently and there's a void a massive
void here that needs to be filled in
and that was the last item in the list
of ugly things that they're seeing rust
for cloud native today
thanks a lot for tuning in i hope this
was a useful presentation and it shared
an experience that you can learn from
if you have any questions i'm happy to
take them now